okay
good morning the uh time being 10 a.m We
Will begin our long day of hearings
for the record my name is Mark McConkey
I chair Public Works and highways and I
want to welcome those here to testify
today to be in our room to our committee
members thank you for joining today
knowing that the weather could be an
issue a little later on
I would just say before we start for the
new members a persons wishing to testify
we'll fill out pink cards
those people in the room that have cards
sometimes will pass them to the person
seated at the end and if that's the case
then just pass them along and come up to
here we have a number of naming bills
today
um and we will get started with uh house
bill 20.
naming a bridge in the town of Merrimack
for The Honorable Richard Dick hinch and
I will ask the prime sponsor
um representative representative NADA to
please introduce yourself and begin
thank you Mr chairman good morning
members of the committee I'm Janine
notter I I'm in my seventh term serving
the town of Merrimack Hillsboro District
12. Nick hinch our late speaker is also
from Merrimack and being the speaker is
the highest position you can get in the
House of Representatives so he's very
important to our town I think most of
you knew him I did make a copy of the
memorial remarks that I gave
our first session in Bedford last term
so I won't read it read the whole thing
but I did I'll leave it with you in case
you want to look it up just just
remember what a wonderful human being he
was so today I'm wearing his pin and I I
helped him pick out this pin because he
he was looking at another one I said no
you can't have that pen he said why
can't I have that pin I said because
that's Steve shirtless pin he goes oh
so we found this one with an eagle in
the flag and then this pin is a roller
skate because when we I campaigned with
representative Mooney and Representative
Bob Healey whose wife is a Merrimack
Town counselor by the way and we would
listen to the 70s music when we're
driving around and representative
Mooney's too young she doesn't know any
of those songs so we would tease her and
talk about rollerblading in the 70s
and I I see representative Boyd just
stepped out um he doesn't want to cry
okay
this pit bill bill Boyd representative
Boyd is the kinch's Legacy
so I wear this pin today
for that reason because we campaigned
for Bill who replaced reps speaker hinch
so anyway you
um you have the details on the bill on
the bit on the bridge it's um a new one
it's over Baboosic Brook on Bedford Road
in Merrimack and I one of the
co-sponsors is also a title counselor
and she's here to testify today as well
as one of his neighbors
do you have any questions for me
does the um we have any questions
Representatives at this point
thank you okay let me just add that his
wife did message me this morning and
she's she's very very pleased with this
bill and uh we will get something from
the Town Council for for you sounds good
and if you would just um get a copy of
the clerk of the documents that you've
um
um we will call on is it
representative Nancy I can't speak what
thank you Mr chair
um good morning uh committee members my
name is Nancy Murphy I'm a
representative for the town of Merrimack
Hillsboro District 12. I'm also
Merrimack Town counselor
um I'm here to ask that you vote in
support of House Bill 20 naming a bridge
in honor of The Honorable Richard
dickinch I think it goes without saying
that we hear know who dick hinge was
um and the town of Merrimack will never
forget who dick hinge was he was an
amazing man who did so much for our
community and represented us well here
in the house and I would ask that you
vote OTP thank you thank you may I ask a
question maybe other members do
um your position with the town was what
I'm a town councilor Merrimack Town
Council okay I'm not familiar with that
it's our local town government okay
um is it possible to add I don't think
it's available today but is it possible
to get a vote by the town
Authority just saying that they're in
favor of this proposal this naming oh
absolutely I will certainly reach out
that would be thankful I appreciate that
I should have reached out earlier in the
process but with that we need that's to
uh to go to fund absolutely thank you
thank you anyone else with a question
seeing none thank you oh thank you very
much
represent Boyd are you planning on
speaking
okay come on forward and we'll just make
sure we have a card
thank you Mr chairman uh through you to
my esteemed colleagues on the Public
Works highways committee Bill Boyd
representing Hillsboro District 12 in
the town of Merrimack here asking you to
support and recommend OTV the naming
bill of the babusik
Brook Bridge after the former New
Hampshire speaker dick hinch
several years ago
we when I sat on the Merrimack Town
Council we the council through our
depart our own DPW we were able to
leverage our own Municipal funds with
DOT funds to rebuild that rebuild that
bridge which significantly when we'd
have a good rainstorm and and now
several years ago after uh 500 basically
a 500 year event occurred that entire
Road was underwater for a couple of days
and representative hinch's work in not
just that bridge but just making sure
that infrastructure was maintained in
our community was certainly a priority
that he had when he sat on the board of
selectman in which he brought forward
when he was elected to the legislature
so in my eyes renaming that bridge after
the former speaker is a very befitting
tribute to a man that was not just
integral within the within the town of
Merrimack some of the stuff that he did
behind the scenes whether it be with
Meals on Wheels or with scouting
um dick was a quiet was a quiet person a
quiet leader working with those programs
acting to promote the betterment of our
community in the town of Merrimack so
there's a lot more
things that I could say outside of for
me personally him being not just a
friend but but a mentor but
the town of Merrimack would not be where
it is today without dick hinch being a
part of that process
for the last 20 years that he was
involved in public service of the town
of Merrimack so naming the bridges like
I said absolutely befitting uh to not
only promote but also to continue his
legacy in our community so I thank you
very much to my colleagues for their
time and I'm happy to entertain any
questions
seeing none thank you thank you Mr
chairman
the last pin card I have here is uh Bob
Scully
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I normally appear in front of
you representing New Hampshire Motor
Transport Association but today I'm just
going to be representing myself I'm
37-year resident of town of Merrimack
dick was a neighbor lived right around
the corner
um he's a great public servant in our
town loved by many if not all he was a
speaker of your body and I think it
would be a an honor and a tribute to
memorialize him by putting his name on
this bridge which is not far from my
home so I would ask you all the kindly
please consider doing that we do support
a lot to pass on House Bill 20 or I do
support thank you thank you
foreign
those are the um the only persons I have
testifying uh today on House Bill 20
that's that's the same one
um we traditionally as a committee
um would would like to uh exec
immediately after a naming bill and we
typically do especially if we were to
have family members in the room and so
forth but one of our one of our hard and
fast for
many many sessions is that we will not
vote
ought to pass on a naming bill without a
letter from whatever the town structure
is whether it be Selectmen or counsel in
your in your point I'm I'm a rural guy
so I think we will
um
instead of closing the hearing I think
we'll just put it into recess for now
but before we do I would like to take a
moment we just stand and recognize
dick hinch who gave an awful lot to this
so we will uh without objection we'll
recess out of the first hearing uh hb20
and unfortunately not knowing how much
time
um items are going to take we were we
will be uh in recess till uh 10 40 where
we will take up
House Bill 52 naming a bridge of
Hinsdale for General John Stark Memorial
Mr chair yes if I may uh just just for
the committee
for those of you who are used to signing
the red clipboard for attendance all its
every every time we meet that has been
done away with we don't have to take
committee attendance any longer we do it
yes
or um and you're you're free to go and
not stay in committee here to that time
if you want to go get a cup of coffee
and walk around I will say though we
passed around
um a document concerning the naming of
little Haystack
or 1 30 hearing on House Bill 213 in our
able committee researcher Chris there
she is in the corner has um I've caught
I've copied you in on a correspondence
her and I had uh Marty and other and
Mike and others on the committee had uh
mentioned uh whether or not we could be
naming a federal a mountain on a federal
piece of property and Christie's
research leads us to believe uh that
we're not able to do that
and this morning she had brought to
light that um
Christy would you mind just saying that
foreign
so so there is a path forward if uh if
they were to feel uh the need to uh go
further with that uh so it's there for
your information you can see it ahead of
time
and um that is that so we will be back
in committee for 10 40.
okay
with my apologies I I for some reason
thought uh at 45 and not 40. so I
apologize uh holding up the committee
so we will the time being
10 45 we will open up the hearing on HB
52 naming of a bridge in Hinsdale is the
General John Stark Memorial Bridge
and we will recognize the prime sponsor
thank you Mr chairman
and I apologize to you and to the other
members of the committee uh for my late
appearance I
have still not had power restored at my
house and
um so that was
responsible for me getting getting up
late and
there's pet I'm passing around a
letter
that was addressed to
John Graham
um who was the chair of this committee
in the last session
um
it is a letter from the select board
in the town of Hinsdale
expressing their unanimous
consent to my suggestion of naming
the bridge which is under construction
right now connecting
instill
I'm also Distributing
a article
on a general Stark
and although he did not cross the
Connecticut River on his way to
Bennington
uh
from Hinsdale it was actually from Fort
number four
in Charlestown
that he crossed and proceeded to
Manchester Vermont
and then down to Bennington
and
I'm not going to read you
the Wikipedia article although there are
some points
that I think
um
one is that
uh
General Stark
who is not a general then but was
fishing and trapping on the baker River
up to where in the baker river is a
tributary that the pemijwasen
and Plymouth
and
when he was there he was taken prison
ER
by the abanaki Indians
um
and they were forced to run a gauntlet
with Warriors who were armed with sticks
Stark
grabbed the stick from the first
Warrior's hand and proceeded to attack
him taking the rest of the Warriors by
surprise
the chief was so impressed with this
heroic Act
that Stark was adopted into the tribe
it also goes on he was ransomed it was
the case
with most of
these prisoners
and
rejoins rejoined
um
the forces fighting against
the Abenaki
and
he was second in command of Rogers
Rangers well
and the um
when they proceeded into Canada
Stark refused to participate in the
attack on the Indian village
because his
foster parents
I think it's worth pointing out
the root nine
which goes from Brattleboro
to Bennington is named the Molly Stark
Trail
there also is in Bennington and the
monument
commemorating the Battle of Bennington
and there is a statue of General Stark
in front of the monument
uh
there's a picture of this statue
and he said it's been as
uh
a rallying point for his uh troops he's
he said they uh
they are your enemies to Redcoats and
the Tories
they are ours
and it's Battle of Bennington and the
subsequent battle at Saratoga
was the one that um
was considered a turning point in the
American Revolution
it prevented that we're going to
surrender prevented the New England
colonies
from being separated from the Middle
Atlantic colonies
it also was instrumental
in
um
persuading the French
to
enter the war
on the side of the American colonies
which was a very important factor like I
said I'm not going to read
this to you folks
you can do that at your leisure but I
would
try to answer any questions or concerns
thank you representative are there
questions
um
seeing there are represent Faulkner
thank you Mr Trent
uh and I know you've been shown history
that shows that General Stark is
important both New Hampshire where he
was from and to Vermont where he
was a hero are you aware of any
objection or other comments from either
the town of Brattleboro or the state of
Vermont to this naming
um no I am I've not received any
um I I do think that
um as former chairman John
John Graham said when I suggested this
naming bill is
um they're not paying for it so they
they don't have any reason to object
thank you representative Abbott I was
going to bring up the same point
um representative Jack thank you Mr
chairman I thank the member for taking
my question uh given there are numerous
other memorializations of uh General
Stark in the state can you tell us what
led you to propose this particular
Bridge as as an additional one
what went well I think it's important
because
um this was of linking
um New Hampshire and Vermont in the same
cause that's what my uh
object was
thank you anyone any other
representatives for the question
committee members
yes please
yeah thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question is this bridge that
you want to rename is it currently
referred to by the locals By Any Other
Name or anything like you know a certain
bridge over the baker River or something
like that
no just to answer your question
um the the existing link
between
Hinsdale is um
and and Brattleboro
uh two Bridges
one the Anna hunt Marsh Bridge
who was a native of Hinsdale
and was also provided the money
in the 1850s uh for starting the
Brattleboro Retreat which is a
organization
um that's devoted to mental health
issues in in Brattleboro
um there was another bridge in the boat
going from Hinsdale
to the island in the middle
middle of the Connecticut River which is
the property of the State of New
Hampshire
that is the
um Yale Carnegie
Memorial Bridge he was also
a native of Hinsdale
and
was
very
um
important figure in the uh
pre-civil War
newspaper publishing business he was in
with or
Forest Greeley
and others
these two Bridges
were constructed in 1924.
so they're going to be a hundred years
old
next year and both of them because of
their superstructure
are not considered really safe
when trailers trailer trucks have to go
through
they have to wait till there isn't any
oncoming traffic
because they're
boxes are so high
that they don't wouldn't wouldn't clear
the superstructure of the bridge so they
have to swing into the middle of the
road
and then
swing back
and do repeat the process when they get
to the other side of the bridge
so um
and although the construction of this
bridge has been delayed
because of like many other things a
labor shortage
um and it was supposed to be open for
traffic in October of 2024
I mean that has now been delighted laid
too early in
um
the
thank you representative Newton are you
satisfied
okay thank you
um thank you Mr chair uh just to clarify
what you're proposing to rename
is the new bridge the one that's under
construction
and the status of the existing Bridges
is still to be determined is that
correct what the plan is is that they
the old bridges will be just open for
thank you and and to follow up and those
bridges are still going to retain their
name yes okay thank you representative
seeing none thank you representative for
uh seeing no other uh Pink cards no
other testimony
um I would like to
uh recess for
five minutes if I could and I would like
the um to caucus and I would like to
have the Republican members meet in that
time in my office
so we will recess for seven minutes so
it's all right the Democrats meet at
caucus in the office here or I'll just
soon take you out of the room we're
going to go in the other room all right
okay all right okay thank you so me
foreign
all right we will
um we will come out of recess
um caucus and uh we will we will move
into uh executive session
is that correct correct okay and at this
time that I would accept a motion
Mr chairman yes uh yes I move ought to
pass on House Bill 52.
motions been made ought to pass is there
by the clerk
and when you have sufficient time uh the
clerk will call the roll
and you'll answer in the affirmative or
thank you Mr chair
representative Cloutier yes
the clerk votes yes
representative fadolfi
representative Newton yeah
representative Kaczynski
did I get that name right
thank you
representative Melvin
yes
representative bogert
representative Connor
representative Jack yes
yes
representative Edgar
I
representative Faulkner yes
representative Newman yes
representative Eaton
representative Peterson
yes
representative vallone yes
aye
vote is 18-0 ought to pass Mr chair
thank you Mr clerk
um
House Bill uh any objective about
consent calendar I mean okay thank you
reminder yeah is there is there anyone
that objects to putting this well naming
yeah
would you uh represent would you prefer
to does it matter to have it on consent
or non-consent
so okay
motion made to be on consent are there
any opposed to putting the bill on
consent
you're in favor of putting the bill on
consent signify by raising your hand or
saying aye
aye okay thank you the bill will go on
that's a good start
the um 1115 we're right on time here
um I would like to open up the hearing
um House Bill 189 renaming a portion of
Route 140 in gilmington on in honor of
private first class Nicholas Conyer
okay
um thank you sorry for the delay uh
represent boys do you do we have a card
are you the one presenting yes
oh okay with committee members turn your
microphones off please read
gotcha thank you I'm sorry for the delay
no problem good morning Mr chair and
members of the public works and Highway
committee my former committee
um today I come before you
um to support House Bill 189 the prime
sponsor Douglas trottier representative
trottier could not make it today but um
I just wanted to present the facts
behind this bill
um private first class cornier was born
in Concord New Hampshire and was a
resident of the town of Gilmanton he
graduated from Guilford New Hampshire
High School in 2000 in 2005 he enlisted
in the U.S army and trained at Fort
Benning Georgia to serve in the Infantry
Division
uh private first class cornea was
assigned to the second Battalion 22nd
infantry first brigade combat team 10th
Mountain division light infantry in Fort
Drum New York join his diet and then he
was deployed to Iraq on May 18 2006 at
25 years old he made the ultimate
sacrifice for our country
while serving the country and the people
in New Hampshire and Iraq joined an act
of War time private first class Corner
area died in Baghdad Iraq from injuries
sustained when an improvised explosive
device AKA IED
um detonated near as Humvee it was
during active combat operations so we're
looking to rename a portion of Route 140
in Gilmanton in his honor
um representative trottier has been in
contact with the Town Administrator she
said there will be no issues with this
um we're in the process of getting a
letter from her in regards to that but I
really hope everybody would support and
honoring this man who gave his life
for our country and our state
thank you representative for their
questions
seeing none thank you sir thank you have
you want to come forward and uh welcome
good morning Mr chairman lady and
gentleman of the committee for the
record my name is Kevin Grady I'm a
25-year veteran of our air force and I'm
a 23 year resident of the town of
Hooksett New Hampshire today I'm here
representing the state veterans advisory
committee uh for those of you unfamiliar
with our work we are chartered by state
RSA 115 colon a-8 if you want to look it
up to so to speak for the veterans in
New Hampshire and we have 20 voting
member organizations that support
veterans in the state and these are
names that would be familiar to you the
American Legion the disabled American
veterans the Veterans of Foreign Wars
the Air Force Army Navy Marine Corps
associations and some guards
associations we even have a couple of
motorcycle groups like Rolling Thunder
if you're familiar with the work that
those folks do
um one of the things that we do every
year is uh and I'm the legislative chair
I look through all the bills that have
better impact and when we see one that
has a has a veteran impact we come and
tell you what we think we take a
position on it and we tell you you tell
you what we think of it
um our policy is any time that that that
we have one of our fallen soldiers uh or
Sailors or Airmen or Marines or now
Guardians for the space force that that
dies serving our country and a town
wants to name a bridge or a road after
that person we full fully support that
and we did vote to unanimously support
this bill
um
the one thing that I would I would I
would tell you as I as I kind of wrap
things up is we we really do enjoy it
when you're going to sponsor a bill that
has veteran impact you you let us know
and we can look things over and and if
if you need help with language or you
need uh to know what the sort of the
corporate memory history is on a certain
topic we can certainly do that and that
keeps me from having to do my least
favorite thing in the whole world which
is to come to a committee and say that
we don't support something that's
designed to support veterans so uh if
you if you want to come see us want to
come to one of our meetings we can
certainly uh set that up for you
Our Hope in a bill like this is that
somebody will drive by and will see this
young man's name on a on a placard and
will decide to do what I did which is go
home and and Google his name and and
find out about this person that that
gave the ultimate sacrifice for our
country so we support this bill uh
unanimously and uh subject to your
question sir that's all I wanted to tell
you this morning
um thank you sir the questions of the
committee members
and I want to thank you for making the
offer to run a little research and I've
asked the clerk to uh to copy me in with
your contact info which you have there
so and uh we will fully take advantage
of that I will tell you though we sure
enjoy having someone sit at the desk
every now and then so thank you
all right
um with that in no other uh no other
cards
um I would like to First
acknowledge
um first class
Nicholas cornier uh by standing for a
moment of silence and then I expect to
go into an executive session oh sure I
thank you
the uh to the representative
as soon as we have that letter
acknowledging the town is in full
support then we will exec on that so we
will recess at this point in time I had
a communication from someone earlier and
I'm not sure if it's your bill or not
that someone's working actually to get
us a letter for one of these today so
we're gonna
okay so we might we might get to that
after lunch
um so we'll re recess out of this till
we get further information
for the committee members the new
committee members
um there are
a couple items in this bill hit it on
the head and it talks about the signage
number two uh cost of design
construction maintenance and
installation of any signage or markers
required in a sack shall not be charged
to the state so when when
people are coming forward and proposing
the state is not going to pay for that
Monument so it's important it's in
almost all of these and if it's not we
usually ask that in the second item
being that we're looking for the town to
recognize that they're in favor of The
Proposal
so any questions from the committee on
that
okay so seeing none
11 15 we're back at one o'clock
so the committee will be in recess until
for the committee and I apologize for
wrong side like this all right thank you
it takes a while okay let's start over
again uh I will call the committee to
order and the hearing for our next bill
is House Bill 412 re-establishing a
commission to study Revenue alternatives
to the road toll for funding of
improvements to the state's highways and
bridges and their resulting improvements
and I will call upon the prime sponsor
thank you
Mr chairman illustrious members of
Public Works and highways
I'm I'm here to introduce uh House Bill
412 which is reestablishing a commission
to study Revenue alternatives to the
road toll for funding of improvements to
State highways and bridges and their
I was um I was named uh chairman we met
we met last uh in this in the fall of
this year
um
on this subject matter but we only had
time uh to meet one or two times and it
was time to report the bill out
for the newer members of the committee
um they with with vehicles becoming so
efficient these days in high mileage or
miles to the gallon
uh we have less and less road toll money
that we're taking in the gas tax the
percentage you pay for the state fee
and unfortunately our infrastructure
continues to be not in the best shape
and with uh decreasing Revenue coming in
and that being one of our major sources
for that funding we need to explore how
we're going to go forward
to make up that Revenue loss there's a
second issue in here that the federal
government is mandating in many states
are mandating the end of the internal
combustion engine and we're moving to an
electric model
and once again presently electric cars
aren't paying a fee that that is helping
us subsidize our roads and highways
we've had we've had several bills over
the years on uh trying to um
trying to adjust registration rates so
that we could make up some of that
Revenue but it's fallen on deaf ears
with the legislature
so we have a we have a great working
group we just didn't get there in time
and the speaker is dead set well you
might you might have heard that he
doesn't like commissions
and um this is one that um that he is in
favor of we have a tremendous group
being
Des working with us
and
a good staff
we would like to be able to continue our
work and we know that it's important
enough that we are trying to get this
done early so we can get it before the
legislature so we can go back and and
find these sources to help our highway
system
and with that there are others I believe
that are going to speak to this matter I
don't know that representative evil is
going to be here she was a long-term
member of our committee
and in support and I'm happy to take any
questions Mr chairman okay thank you
representative McConkey any questions of
Representative McConkey
and he quite okay yes restaurant
Faulkner please yes thank you Mr Trump
uh
could you explain what you know uh
let's say what the emphasis of this
committee is commission is uh looking at
sort of the overall
shortfall in terms of funding needs and
also different ways of making it a more
fair
distribution are you doing both of those
things or what what's the balance there
uh yes not only how are we going to make
up that shortfall but long term what are
we going to do going forward to keep the
system financially viable
there there I believe there's others DS
will speak to it on some of the other
issues uh but we're definitely trying to
is the commission
considering
the weight of a vehicle just like they
cars being the same way electric
vehicles go away an awful lot more than
pres presently
um
uh the trucking industry and so forth
during registration fees is paying a
higher amount I don't know if that helps
in the question
uh just wondering if they're considering
thanks chairman
what is going on here okay thank you uh
Mr chairman thank you the chair of the
committee uh
the last three members are sort of out
of the legislature's control are these
are these is this the exact same
composition that you had and are all the
members identified so they can get right
to work and get appointed
thank you for the question
um I believe there is one person that
wasn't re-elected from ways and means
that we would have to make up for but
um all the other appointments have been
made in the past and my understanding
are going to stay
uh the um there is an additional member
that's being added a request to be added
here which would be a member from the
public also so there could be input so
that is the new one
the loan please
all right
so by road toll you mean could you just
give me the we're talking about the
actual tolls as well on the on route
on the highways or
representative we're talking about the
fee that you pay at the pump uh when you
buy a gallon of gasoline road toll
I I have another go right ahead sorry
could I have a do a follow-up go ahead
please so would that commission consider
the the actual tolls that we pay
I'm sorry representative I didn't hear
the last part of your question so the
another source of Revenue are the tolls
that are paid on Route 3 and and on
Route 93 and on Route 95. so is that
part of the discussion as well or for
consideration for generating revenues
thank you they told the tolls are on the
turnpike system
and the Turnpike system funding unless
I'm incorrect is as a separate source of
money so that won't be there perhaps if
I what I should have read was this
paragraph if you wouldn't mind Mr
chairman go ahead please we are to study
the alternatives to the road toll for
electric powered High Hybrid and fuel
efficient vehicles and then study the
emergency vehicle fuels and Technologies
for funding improvements to the state
highways and bridges ensuring that all
Motor Vehicles contribute proportionally
to their impact on New Hampshire's
Highway infrastructure including
Vehicles registered out of state that
may now no longer be subject to the road
toll
okay all right thank you
any further questions okay thank you I
guess representative McConkey your
excuse so who's uh I will now call upon
the next uh person to testify our former
representative and former chair of this
committee uh The Honorable John Graham
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee uh it's kind of unusual to be
City at this end of the spectrum but
it's good to see a lot of you again uh
as many of you know I have supported and
sponsored LED similar legislation in the
past in fact I was involved both of the
studies 2010 and 2012 that are mentioned
in this uh particular piece of
legislation
this study is key to the future of our
highway system in my opinion make no
mistake I'll turn in the fuels primarily
Electric in the near term will continue
to lessen our Highway funding through
the current roll toll system
if you look at what's happening every
year what we take in from gasoline and
Diesel taxes goes down uh by a certain
percentage
what we have done for the last several
terms is take money from the general
fund to plug the the shortfall
um
simply stated fully electric vehicles
pay virtually nothing to the maintenance
and upkeep of our existing Road system
yet the New Hampshire dot is posed to
spend millions of dollars some 17
million in the last 10-year plan alone
and establishing a network of vehicle
electric charging stations across the
state we used
in his vehicle not a single penny of
that charge goes to our Highway fund so
he's using the roads but not paying as I
do for my fully gasoline car
we need to fix this we need to find a
way to ensure that everybody using our
roads pays a portion of the upkeep and
maintenance and to a certain extent the
expansion of the highway system
I know some of you have signed uh pledge
concerning new or raising taxes or fees
I would point out that this is a study
and the opportunity to look at and
perhaps find solutions to the current
problem is now I would urge you to
support this bill and see what
recommendations can come from the
commission
one final note Mr chairman I would
consider changing the date of the final
report to November 1st 2024 with an
interim report due this November veteran
members of the house will realize that
if HB 412 is signed into law it will be
summer before it can become effective
and probably late summer before the
members are actually named by the
speaker or the various
listing there of the Automobile Dealers
Association or wherever
I would suggest an interim study this
November in case there is something that
somebody wants to put in the legislation
for 2024.
um
and also if you take out the fact that
the house precedent is not to meet in
August you lose a whole nother month of
2023. so it doesn't leave a lot of time
to work on a
real study I mean we can do
putting lipstick on that pig as the
saying goes but to do a real study I
think you're going to need the whole
year and a half and everybody actually
looking at it thank you for
consideration
um
that concludes my testimony okay thank
you former representative Graham any
questions of the former I don't have to
take the Vietnam right absolutely well
it's up to a represent Faulkner but I
will
well thank you for taking my question
um I know in the past when this has come
up one of the
arguments brought up is that
raising the fee charged electric
vehicles would discourage their
their adoption I think that perhaps
events over the last year have changed
that quite a bit is that something that
uh one is that changes the dynamic but
also May
say that we need to get going in order
to get ahead of the game last year when
we were looking at this very issue when
I was sitting on the other side
um it was the first time that
um
some of the environmental groups des and
others came in and supported at least
looking at this problem
electric vehicles are going to be a
major factor in the future of
Transportation in this this country even
um tractors and trailers are now being
developed and tested that are fully
electric so to stick our head in the
sand is not it I think the time is now
to study it and see where we go always
before before last term it was always we
shouldn't have to pay anymore because
we're saving the planet but if you're
not paying for the roads then you're
going to be driving on gravel again so
it's kind of a
a mix here and we're paid not wheat you
guys are paid to make the serious
um
policy decisions on how we're going to
maintain
um our road system throughout the state
without having to rely on the fact that
maybe we'll have a surplus that we can
plug 50 million dollars of general fund
money into the highway fund for uh for
upkeep of our system
okay thank you former Senator Graham any
other questions uh yes go ahead please
um okay I didn't I'll take you and then
go if you don't mind I'm sorry I didn't
it's basically first who I see first go
ahead please okay thank you thank you
for taking my question
um I want to ask you of your historical
nature how long has this commission been
active
there this commission was only active
last term
um it came out of a whole different
process
um and unfortunately it did not was not
able to meet we did it in an election
year and so it did not meet all that
often and the real recommendation of the
the commission at that point was to kick
the cannon and
re-reestablish it in this year the
problem of funding
has been around for over 20 years my
first term in
2001 uh maybe 2002 then speaker Chandler
appointed myself and several members of
this committee to a study committee to
look at funding of road toll and how we
were going to pay for I-95
um
it's not going to get any better it
hasn't gotten any better in 20 some
years we need to look at that the only
bright spot that I've seen in 20 years
is we managed to figure out a way to do
um
uh propane and other Natural Gas
powered vehicles and how they would pay
um into the road toll and I would make
that very clear that we need to make
sure that if we do something that that
money goes into the road toll in law and
not part of the general fund because the
people down the hall if they see it in
general fund it's up for them to decide
how to use it
all right yes representative Newman and
followed by uh representative Bogart go
ahead police yes thank you for taking my
question
has the car seat Institute or would they
or have they been able to contribute
anything to the commission's work the
car seat I think that's the car seat
Institute from una studies not to my
knowledge but if the commission wanted
to ask for some help from from them or
Dartmouth is always offering to help
with things to the to this committee
um then they're welcome to do that but
there's no guarantee that they'll take
up the challenge
okay thank you representative Bogart
please
yes thank you for taking my question
um
has it been considered to get rid of the
fee altogether for uh oil-based products
our combustion engines and stuff and
then go to a mileage charge and that way
you don't rely on any uh
as we grow in the future the different
vehicles and what propels them is going
to be different as we move so it it has
been considered I I've been on studies
that have looked at uh vehicle miles
traveled formula the the real problem
that we encounter with that other than
the political side is the fact that we
are a small state and a lot of our
citizens travel and work in other states
so unless you have some kind of compact
with
um
surrounding states or a national vehicle
while traveled formula
we end up trying to determine okay John
Graham you travel 50 000 miles last year
but I claim that 40 000 of it was out of
state so should I have to pay for all
fifty thousand since I'm paying gas tax
in in a different state that's the
nutshell of the whole vehicle miles
traveled problem is that it is
um
based on
total travel and how do I differentiate
what I'm doing in New Hampshire to pay
into the New Hampshire road toll as
opposed to what I'm doing outside of the
state and that's particularly true if we
start getting big rigs that are fully
electric which is not in that far in the
future
okay thank you thank you uh further
questions a former representative Graham
from members of the committee
okay scene on thank you very much for
your testimony former summer and welcome
back
um okay next witness please
um
you have
anybody else who wishes to testify
either for or against House Bill four
one two
anybody else wishes to testify for or
against
four one two
um seeing uh none
um and I don't know if any of you I know
some of you in the audience I don't know
if you've had wanted to sign the blue
sheet which is fine but I do not see
anybody I do not have any more pink
cards so I will now close the public
okay
um
okay thank you
all right testimony there's
representative Graham's written
testimony
um
now I don't what did the chairman
chairman I think is left to go to
another hearing
um
because I think this is one of the bills
that we wanted to exec
um
yes sir okay all right he is there okay
so I just closed the public hearing uh
Mr chairman so you want to preside at
thank you John okay you're welcome
all right we will move into executive
session for house bill without objection
do we have a motion
Mr chairman yes recognize I move off to
second to Mr chairman
um motion made by clear and seconded by
Boyd
any discussion
the chairman I think this is probably
the one of the most important bills that
we're going to deal with today certainly
and I think we need to do what we can to
expedite this pass this bill today if no
one objects and then send to the house
for for a vote next Thursday and
hopefully the house can pass it with not
little or no debate and send it to the
Senate and you know hopefully the Senate
will act on in the next month or so
because we've got to get this commission
re-established as a member of this
commission I want plenty of time to
study this whole problem and if we're
going to meet a deadline on November 1st
2023 I think we've got to do it as soon
as possible thank you thank you
representative
yes I just wondered if um you if we
wanted to amend
this bill
um two
is former
chairman Graham indicated that to change
so thank you I I um I stepped out in the
hallway with representative Graham
chairman Graham and asked him where he
and his his thought was that I believe
he was saying to keep an interim report
for November 1st 2023 and a final for
2024 November okay that that was his
suggestion
are are you looking to make an amendment
to that or just discussion at this point
if
okay thank you yes representative am I
correct that if we do have a committee
amendment that we have to send that to
OLS and then postpone this yeah session
thank you Mr chair I I and I would I
would like to say I'm not a big favor of
sending things over to the other side
the wall there to correct something but
I think it would allow if we were to get
this bill out today and we were to get
it on the floor
um then um we can we can take further
action because there are members there
are members that are very active in the
Senate and if after discussion we think
that's right we can handle it then
yes
you just echoed what I was going to
suggest thank you
any further discussion
one item I believe the original Bill
1040 which set up the commission we
passed it and with an amendment that
representative Faulkner worked on and we
sent at the Senate I think they further
amend amended it to take out some things
uh deal with some things like I think
they took out the Senate member I don't
think there's any Senators on the
commission so it's possible that the
Senate could very well amend it you know
and with some of the suggestions right
former representative Graham suggested
thank you
any further discussion
thank you Mr chair
clerk votes yes
representative fadolfi yes
representative Newton yeah
representative Kaczynski yes
representative Boyd
Boyd votes eye
representative Melvin
yes
representative bogert
representative Connor
representative Martin
wow okay yes I'm sorry Mark
thank you
representative Abbott yes
representative Edgar hi
representative Faulkner yes
representative Newman yes
representative Peterson yes
chairman McConkey hello Ty
Mr chair of the vote is 18-0 in favor of
ought to pass
thank you
the um Financial we'll put it on the
all right so I'm gonna have to switch
in close executive Century yeah
we will uh close the executive session
um on House Bill 4112 our next hearing
will be shortly at 1 30 which will be
house bill
two one three
all right
this one right okay good thanks guys
okay I'm gonna call this a Committee
hearing to order on House Bill 213
renaming little Haystack Mountain to
mount because I'm going to murder Korea
skill okay
I'll try to remember that representative
milts but no guarantees I'm not polish
Chicago Polish oh okay good I'll have to
take you with me when I need to help
pronouncing polish words
all right
um I just was on the phone a few minutes
ago with the prime sponsor she's going
to be a little bit late due to a
Communications misunderstanding and I'm
not going to get into that but I think
people are here including the
co-sponsors and people who want to
testify so I'm going to take them first
and hopefully the prime sponsor will
show up shortly uh and to be able to
testify so I'm going to call now upon
one of the the Bill's co-sponsors
representative Mike Moffett uh in
support of the bill
welcome to Public Works and highways
representative thank you Mr it's great
to be here for the first time
uh yes I was asked a co-sponsor would
say I agree too happily uh so uh to get
right to it I'm originally from kowas
County uh New Hampshire's True North
Country uh Groveton High School grad one
of my classmates fathers one of my
classmates father he had one father it
was a conservation officer up in the
North Country his name is Arthur Muse
when he retired a mountain in northern
coast County was named after him and you
can find Muse Mountain on a map today
um so Mr Muse retired they had a
testimonial for him my friend's dad and
when he spoke at his testimonial he
thanked all concern for naming a
mountain after him
um and he said that he'd earlier driven
by the mountain with his kids to show
them the mountain that now bore the
family name uh but at the testimony he
said he had one concern about the
process he shared that when they drove
by the newly named Muse Mountain he
noticed it was significant logging and
lumbering operations going on on one of
the mountains slopes so he then posed a
question that Drew some laughter at the
testimonial he asked
why are all these people cutting trees
down on my Mountain without my
permission
so he indeed had a sense of humor but
significantly uh the mountain stayed in
his Muse Mountain not but not arthimus
Mountain Muse Mountain it was a way to
honor the entire family which ties into
this
um Arthur Muse's parents lived in
Bristol and his dad was a World War one
hero who did some amazing things in the
trenches in no man's land in World War
One the Great War and he was awarded the
Victoria Cross that's Britain's highest
award for Valor he was given this medal
by the king of England
in a special ceremony so Muse Mountain
was a way to honor the whole family and
indeed uh far beyond the single
individual
so the fact that I'm speaking about it
in 2023 goes to the fact that naming
this mountain after after the Arthur
Muse is a way to keep memories in
history alive so it brings us to HB 213
renaming little Haystack mountain is
Mount Kosciuszko the intent is to honor
Another Hero tadius casiusco polish
engineer Statesman military leader who
was a hero
in in Belarus France Lithuania Poland
and the United States
he came to America in 1776 uh he
provided invaluable service to General
Washington and our continental army he
was a military architect he designed and
oversaw the construction of of numerous
fortifications state-of-the-art
fortifications to include West Point
so when the war ended the Continental
Congress promoted him to General in the
Continental Army in 1783. so so renaming
little Haystack as Mount Kosciuszko is a
wonderful way to honor a wonderful
Revolutionary War hero
the way that Muse Mountain
honors the whole Muse family
in Mount Kosciuszko if or when it
happens
uh would also honor our greater Polish
American Community I have to share that
on my way up here uh
Stanley
collegnicki you all see him downstairs
uh he's the one with the accent he's
down there right now and I he was aware
of this hearing and he was very excited
that we're at least talking about a
wonderful polish or Polish American if
you will hero
um and there are many the Polish
American Community uh of course would
love and embrace as he just told me
downstairs something like this somehow
someday
um to honor their part in our history
I'm a history guy uh The Honorable Paul
mursky some of you may know uh was uh
from Grafton County he's been a member
of this house for for many many terms uh
very supportive and excited about again
somehow someday trying to do something
to honor
so anyway to finish this up out in front
of our state house not far from the
statue of Daniel Webster is a monument
uh it was placed here fairly recently
last year I think and uh it honors the
Marquis De Lafayette who came here from
France to fight in our Revolutionary War
Lafayette was perhaps George
Washington's favorite General and
remarkably in case you didn't know the
Marquee General Lafayette actually once
addressed this legislature in our very
uh reps Hall in 1825.
which is perhaps why he has a monument
right out by not far from Daniel
Webster's statue
so
the fact that his Monument is in front
of the state house uh is a way for us to
remember
Lafayette who came here from France he
has a mountain named after him many of
us have been up Mount Lafayette it's on
the Franconia Ridge not too far from
Haystack
and uh
you know some have said we should keep
little Haystack as a name Haystack his
name it's easier to say than Mount
casuco which uh there may be some truth
to that yeah you're right
uh not looking at the chair necessarily
I had to practice myself
um but you know what instrument had to
make a 911 call from from up there and
there have been some some recent deaths
up on Frank Franconia Ridge Trail
the loop up there
um but I don't think that's a
showstopper in any sense uh is classic
yusco harder to say than many of the
indigenous Native American Indian names
we find throughout New Hampshire uh
Monadnock pemijowash at kanka magus
musalaki
so
um but others have said that it could be
expensive and again uh if somehow if or
when this hopefully somehow moves
forward in some fashion
uh yes we'd have to eventually change
some names on maps and books uh that
wouldn't have to happen overnight these
things that you know happen it's a
process and it in updating names is
something that
um sometimes takes time and doesn't
necessarily have to be done immediately
uh on the apps or the maps
and finally
um we're not taking anyone's name down
in this process okay the mountain was
named for a haystack
okay you know what Christopher Columbus
okay it's it's not uh taking any other
name off the maps or off the books now
the of course and you know better than
than I do that something like this would
entail a need for some federal
um
coordination
I mentioned Muse mountain and I'm not
sure that this property up in coax
County was part of the national forest I
I don't know how they did that I see
that Muse Mountain my named after my
friend's dad is on the map
um I'm not sure if it's in the national
forest and I I understand that that is
an issue to to address there would need
to be some coordination with the
Department of the Interior but there are
processes and as someone said earlier
today if we can put a man on the moon
why not put Thaddeus Casa usko's name on
the mountain so anyway uh thank you for
your time and attention I was happy to
be asked to co-sponsor this and I I hope
that the committee can um now that
you'll own this bill if you can somehow
uh
shine a light do something with it and
I'd be happy to take any questions if
they're already thank you thank you
but questions of Representative Moffett
from the committee yes representative
Jack please can the chair have a copy of
your written testimony thank you
certainly
okay and any other questions uh of the
representative Moffett from members of
the committee
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony representative Moffett thank
you Mr chair and I did also email these
remarks uh to you all uh via legislative
email okay thank you um I think I see
the the the prime sponsor of the bill in
the room representative Dusty now you're
here thank you for coming please come
and because you're the prime sponsor
otherwise I would have had you come
first but I wanted to get going because
several people wanted to testify and
again I on be half of the committee I
apologize I should have worked with the
chair to catch the error but we all make
mistakes and so I'm sorry but I'm glad
you're here to to testify and Enlighten
the committee about this bill and why
you support it so please go ahead
representative dutse it was a fast drive
up from Nashville and I was very lucky
okay yes we we very much appreciate it
anyway
um thank you colleagues
um for hearing this bill uh I presented
I filed this bill on behalf of a
constituent uh and my constituents are
here uh Mr draza and his son to
recognize again uh General Thaddeus and
I always pronounce it kashuko okay so
that may be a wrong
um but in understanding the contribution
he made to the Revolutionary War and the
fact that I don't think little Haystack
really
um represents anything historical I
thought it was a good idea to go ahead
and and file the bill
my understanding in doing the research
is that on the state level we can change
the name of the mountain however in
order for it to
um be recognized it would have to go
through the federal government through
the board of geographic names and then
that would be something that we would
have to prepare for I contacted the
Appalachian Mountain Club to see if they
had any concerns about it and they are
neutral on the naming of the bill I also
contacted a fish and game and some of
their rescue Personnel to see if they
had an issue with it
um with all due respect there is an
issue with the pemi search and rescue
and they do plan on sending a a response
however I did give him the the date of
February 3rd so
um it's not in preparation for this
meeting yesterday I also contacted the
State library to try to to have them do
some research on
the general kosuko to see if he had
fought for us actually in New Hampshire
and to get any background on little
Haystack that hasn't come to me yet but
when it does I'll forward it over to the
committee so I've tried to do my due
diligence on this I think it's a good
idea
um the Polish diaspora in the United
States is the second largest outside of
Poland outside of Warsaw I believe
um so I think to recognize them would be
a great honor for the State of New
Hampshire and for all of our polish
citizens thank you okay
thank you representative Dusty questions
of Representative Dusty from members of
the committee
any questions of Representative Dusty
okay thank you representative and one
thing I forgot and I know you you got
here in a hurry could you please fill
out a pink card I will okay thank you
very much
okay uh next I will call upon I may have
trouble with this name too it's probably
a Polish name representative Tom
pelosiak plow Jack okay thank you very
much
welcome to
thank you chairman and the committee for
taking my testimony
um the
angle
size name is Project I go by uh for the
Polish dialect is pleasure for the
Russians is plushie
so whatever dialect you speak and this
is the same with thaddeus's I use the
four syllables I was brought up with the
Russian the maternal side in the farm so
that's why I was brought up with all
those uncles pushing me so I got the
Russian accent so
uh represent Dusty
did all the research representative
Moffett has gave him the history I will
be real short
Thaddeus has been worldwide known
from the mount the highest mountain
Australia
to all of Europe almost he he refused to
work with Napoleon
and the Tsar Alexander the first because
they would not do give any guarantees
for liberty or social form reforms for
the serfs and the indentured servants
throughout his life
all of his efforts
in
let's just say battle was for civil
change
it wasn't for his nobility it wasn't for
government it was for the people
I'm not sure
um represent Moffett mentioned but he
fought throughout the colonies in South
and North Carolina also he's a very
um
important in protecting some people with
his engineering skills crossing rivers I
believe that was in North Carolina I'm
not the history major so
I just wanted to add to it
that the the penny rescue and others I
had emails from
was concerned about the pronunciation of
name the change on search and rescue
I've been in the EMS for 44 years active
since
1973 till my retirement in 2015 because
my move from Grafton to
a town to Center Harbor Center Harbor
has commercial
and they need a fire cert one for their
fire uh at this age I'm not going to do
my cert one training
now being a dispatcher in EMS
I'm back from the old
switch toggle before the cad systems I'm
not up to the enhanced 9-1-1
but I'm assuming
that this is even more improved we have
always
had duplicate names if you had to change
shames that was there by the toggle for
years I can still see the paper and it
taped over many times of the old names
or an area
so when someone calls in and they say
you know I'm stuck
I took this trailhead
dispatch I am assuming if it's like
everyone I worked from there you know
where you're going
and from that point on you can get any
other little details the old name little
haystack
it's been changed three years ago that
should be in a cad system still as a
historical name so with that I don't see
any problem with the search and rescue
and I wanted to bring that that's my
main thing here
um since the other two Representatives
sponsors covered most everything and I
thank you for allowing me this time
and for questions thank you sir any
next and I'm probably going to murder
this last name again Mr Daryl derezia of
okay so if unless anybody objects you if
you want to both come up at the same
time I have two separate cards but it'll
okay you have some yeah if you have
all right all set all set yes sure okay
thanks thanks for the opportunity to
speak here just to make it quick uh to
give you a quick uh story of the whole
idea here uh I'm a life lifelong New
Hampshire resident and lifelong hiker of
the White Mountains they're very
important to me I you know uh
and in recently reading uh some of the
history of the Revolutionary War I I
read a lot in depth about Kosciusko the
character and his his life story
and the sort of a light bulb just went
off in my head when I looked at this
Ridge with with the names Lafayette
Lincoln and Liberty and how koshko fits
perfectly to me with those other names
because of his similarities to Lafayette
and then the uh Thomas Jefferson has the
famous quote calling Kosciusko the
purest son of Liberty he's ever known
so this Malco would be right next to
mount Liberty
uh so it just seems to me to be a
perfect fit uh and then also it's a
perfect fit for New Hampshire because of
our uh part because of the State slogan
uh the Live Free or Die thing to me
because a character that really lived
that phrase more than many people I've
ever heard of you know fighting for
freedom in multiple different countries
and he also was a lifelong advocate for
individual freedoms uh you know he freed
uh his own serfs in his home country of
Poland he also wrote a will uh
dedicating all the money that he'd want
that he'd earned fighting in our
Revolution to free and educate as many
American slaves as possible
so to me he fits in perfectly with the
state of New Hampshire he also
during he was huge in the Saratoga
campaign of the Revolutionary War which
was one of the bigger uh you know parts
of the Revolutionary War with the
British trying to get control of the
Hudson River
and um
so he just uh you know to me he just uh
it's a it's a perfect fit for our for
our state in in the fact that he fought
in that Saratoga campaign he fought with
multiple New Hampshire regiments I know
uh John Stark a character from New
Hampshire also was huge and it was just
they were very uh important in stopping
General burgoyne's Advance south from uh
Lake Champlain and trying to split the
colonies in half uh Kosciusko was just
very important in in his his
contributions that he did at Fort
Ticonderoga and also in Saratoga which
is where the actual final battles took
place and it was it was largely due from
what I understand so koshko's uh you
know selection of that of that land the
height and the way he utilized The High
Ground and just the strategy of the war
so he was huge in in that Saratoga which
was actually the foot where Burgoyne
actually surrendered I think it was the
only time that British forces had ever
surrendered in the field there's uh
something like that so
so Kosciusko was just there's that has
that connection with New Hampshire
because uh you know he with the New
Hampshire regiments and the Live Free or
Die thing
and uh I uh
I think that's about it really um
you know uh and then I know that uh you
know Mount Eisenhower I know was changed
in the 70s uh so it's not that something
there's been name changes that have
happened before
and uh and that was changed I just feel
like it's I just feel like when it
really the
the light bulb just went off for me when
I when I just looked at this Ridge that
we have with Lafayette Lincoln and
Liberty and reading about Castro's going
to me I was like the light bulb went off
like he fits in perfectly with all those
other names
you know so I just feel like it's a good
idea and I feel like New Hampshire has a
very good opportunity here to to do this
I know that's one of the most popular
hikes in the state thousands of people
sometimes do it a day in the summer
months and you get people from all over
that are doing it so it's a very
important uh part of our state and I
just feel like it's a very good
opportunity for our for our for the
State of New Hampshire to do okay thank
you uh yours is yours
drazier right okay okay yeah uh so Daryl
drazier do you want anything to add to
Zach's testimony probably don't yeah I
don't want to waste time you know he
pretty much my son covered it pretty
much I think if there's questions we're
going to do and we have all right yes
absolutely questions of either one of
okay yeah see none thank you for your
okay I apologize I'm still getting uses
is there anybody else who wishes to
testify either for or against House Bill
213 here today I do not have any more
pink cards I assume there isn't but I
just want to be absolutely sure because
we've allotted an hour for testimony on
this for this public hearing but before
I close it I want to be sure everybody's
had a chance to testify either for or
against
all right
seeing none I will close the public
okay yeah I think what we're going to do
now at the testimony hearing didn't take
as long as I think we had anticipated so
our next hearing is not until 2 30 on
199 so I'm going to recess the public
hearing on this and I may we may have an
executive session later on this bill but
we're going to wait for a few minutes to
see if the chair who's in another
committee right now is going to come
back okay thank you very much everybody
the time being 2 30.
um I would like to exec on House Bill
213.
um
Mr chair I vote itl I would like to move
itl on HB 213. thank you representative
moves itl and House Bill 213 is there a
second second
and the second would be representative
Jack
uh discussion
I would um I would like to make a couple
comments
um
on the bill before us I understand the
co-sponsors brought in some information
that may have conflicted with
information that we had at the time or I
should say it's more a path forward for
how they could rename this mountain
uh there's still my understanding that
our our committee Public Works and
highways cannot do that naming because
it's a federal property uh Federal lands
but it appears that if they were to move
on with the federal delegation
and pursue through the
I'm sorry the board that they spoke of
geological naming I apologize for uh
being
not clear on that uh but it there's
there seems to be from the sponsors uh
conversation with that geological group
that's in charge in naming Federal
properties that that is a bit of a hill
to climb and they're going there's a lot
of work that needs to be done uh to get
there after thought perhaps the best
vehicle for us is to
um is to itl this bill at this time and
let the co-sponsors
move forward with the federal delegation
the geological group and see if this is
something that they feel reasonably
assured can happen and then the
co-sponsors possibly could come back
with a house next year with a house
resolution that the house were to
support the renaming which would then be
a benefit to them
with uh with the feds and with that
geological naming group so it's I will
be voting
in favor of itl is there any other
discussion
yes
it's more of a question
as I am uh thank you Mr chairman uh I'm
not aware of what Ito means so okay
thank you thank you and it's uh and I
apologize for you for myself for that
itl is inexpedient to legislate
um it ends the bill
for this year and if someone wants to
bring something back next time we could
retain the bill that's another motion we
could have we could move ought to pass
to approve uh but with so much work to
be done I don't think that retaining it
would be the right move at this time
any other questions
yes representative thank you Mr chairman
I would hope that our explanation in the
uh
calendar would indicate that we
don't want this to be taken as a slight
on the
on Kosciusko or on the
polish
Pride that went behind this uh my
brother is a technical problem that
we're trying to address
thank you representative and I think
that's uh certainly Our intention of how
this would be worded
person boy yes thank you Mr chairman
just anecdotally 2003 the legislature
voted and enacted to change Mount clay
to mount Reagan
and it was seven years later when it was
brought before the federal Board of
geographical names and they voted
against changing the name of Mount clay
to mount Reagan so to this day when you
look at the AMC the United States
Geological Survey group
um obviously the Appalachian Mountain
Club they all rely upon the board of
geographical names so that they're able
to align their their their mapping
information so
even though to this day it's enacted as
Mount Reagan federally it still
recognize this Mount clay so I think the
approach that you're asking this
committee and the responses of the bill
to pursue I think is an appropriate
venue considering it was seven years
before that particular board addressed
the issue of changing uh clay to Reagan
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative anyone else wish to speak
from the committee
seeing no further I would are you ready
Mr clerk I would ask the clerk to call
the roll thank you Mr chair
for the motion itl in expedient to
legislate representative Cloutier yes
the clerk votes yes
representative Newton yes
representative Kaczynski
representative Boyd
Boyd votes eye representative Melvin
yes
representative bogert
representative Connor
representative Jack yes
representative Abbott yes
representative Edgar
aye
representative Faulkner yes
representative Newman
yes
representative
eaten
representative Peterson yes
and chairman McConkey chairman votes I
thank you
any thoughts on the consent calendar
with a properly written blurb
and the opposition to that
suggests that we put it on the consent
calendar
I will call the this hearing
close executive session
did I give you all the paperwork first
1999 nope no no
time being 2 37 and I call the public
hearing to order on HB 199 Bill relative
to making an appropriation to the Carol
Stratford and koas County Freight Line
Improvement projects
and recognize the prime sponsor
representative McCarthy McConkey
thank you Mr chairman
members of Public Works and highways
I sit here to uh to offer
to enter House Bill 199 relative to the
making of appropriation to the Carol
Stratford and cross county Freight rail
Improvement projects
as a sitting member of Public Works and
highways for a number of years
I've been in a position with similar
funding as chair and vice chair it's my
understanding that
this appropriation
has been in at least one in in four
Capital budgets prior to this and three
in another Capital at three the other
rail uh three times in the capital
budget
the gentleman behind me that represent
these Rail lines will give you a lot
more detail
what we have traditionally done in
public works is
we take this request in it's been common
in the past for this committee to retain
the bill
and and then bring it back in during the
capital budget process
and incorporate it into there so it is
it is my hope
that the committee would see clear to uh
to retain
I just want to make a couple notes that
this is on our this is on a freight line
these are Freight Lines this has nothing
to do with passenger
and for the newer members
um it would be nice to run uh passenger
service over these but there are
standards that aren't even close to
being met
on the tracks and the rails to permit
that to happen
so I'm in I'm in the area that of the
of one of these freight lines and the
important and the important thing to
consider is
that every one of these
railroad cars that's carrying material
in and out especially with the aggregate
operation keeps thousands of tractor
trailers off our road that that weigh a
tremendous amount and so we have we have
seen benefits in the past I'm sure these
gentlemen will address that going
forward and
um
I I just hope you'll give them due
consideration
thank you Mr representative McConkey
does everybody have any questions for
representative McConkey
the chair would like to represent today
is a one of those red letter days where
we recognize all our old past chairman
of the Public Works committee we had
representative Graham here earlier and
we now have ex-representative his
microphone please
it's Noob to me there we go it's uh good
to be uh back in room 201
3 I guess
I'm on the other side of the wall but uh
yeah I'm here today to um
to speak in favor of House Bill 199 and
following up on the uh chairman
mcconkey's comments uh
hoping you retain this so it can be
considered in the capital budget process
the reason we do this is that we can
fully vet
this issue so you can understand what
the projects are and be able to ask
questions
there are 603 Short Line railroads in
the country they all they all carry
Freight there's no passenger rails 603
is easy to remember
uh 28 of all Freight in the country runs
by rail and of that about 20 is on the
short lines the short lines are like you
know the main class one railroads like
CSX Union Pacific Canadian national
Norfolk Southern Amtrak to name a few
those are like the main arteries of rail
but off of those are veins and
capillaries and those are the short
lines that actually bring it right to
the customers
environmentally and economically Freight
rail is very efficient uh Freight rail
can move one ton of goods 470 miles on
one gallon of diesel fuel it's the
safest mode of transporting Freight
because you take it's on the railroads
it's it goes through controlled
Crossings gets it off the roads as a
chairman of mentioned previously
um by diverting millions of strucks off
highways it also lets lessens the
highway wear and tear not just safety
issues but the wear and tear on the
highways and that reduces state federal
and local Highway budgets
so the last four Capital budgets have
had some sort of in both democratic and
con and republican-controlled
legislatures has had some form of
infrastructure repair now we say
infrastructure we're not talking about
cars or operating expenses we're talking
solely the tracks themselves
um the the tracks being the rails the
ties the ballasts the railroad bed and
the state for its part
maintains a 10-year lien on any loans
they give or loans or loans in the past
and sometimes these and these um these
grants these 50 50 grants matched by the
railroads the partnership between the
the rail and the state
maintains a a lien on the tracks and
that's uh you know so they they have
protection so if the railroad ever going
out of business track reverts the state
of New Hampshire so the state has an
interest in keeping the infrastructure
up just as they spend money
and the on the roads highways Bridges
um and other forms of Transit like um
like the buses none none of the these
603 shortland railroads would exist
except for the partnership with their
States and the federal government
um I have a
PowerPoint here that I gave you and you
know it's pretty self-explanatory but
I'll just go through the pages here
quickly you know first it describes what
what we as nhn New Hampshire North Coast
do we run a 42 mile Short Line from
Rollinsford up to Ossipee used to be
part of the b m
it's 160 year old
Freight Line it's been there been
running continuously for 160 years
um used to have a ski train that some
people remember in those parts that was
just continued in the 60s
so the line was purchased in two
sections 86 and 93 by the Boston from
the Boston main railroad to Boston Santa
gravel
who created the New Hampshire North
Coast Railroad now the largest freight
commodity on this rail is concrete sand
manufactured up in Ossipee
um
better ICB Aggregates and our second
biggest is of propane we also do steel
philosophy arrogance take sand they wash
it prepare for concrete sand
um
5200 of those cars
of of the freight of the 6150 are sand
related now about two-thirds of those go
to Boston the other third goes to um
North Rochester for distribution right
there in the in the New Hampshire area
propane that all comes in that's propane
that comes into a tank farm that you'll
see a picture of on the next page and uh
they've stored in the large tanks on the
property and then the individual trucks
come out and they disperse that
they will they are hopeful to take even
more by that because it's cheaper and
the cheaper they bring in the propane
the less expensive it is for the
homeowners on the other end
um so the the statistics here are
showing you that the the present loads
right now at six six hundred fifteen
thousand tons that's uh six thousand one
hundred and fifty hundred ton rail cars
by the way the propane cars are just as
heavy as the freight as the as the sand
all these cars are filled to the maximum
so I mean that's the only way it makes
it efficient so so whether it's rebar
you know recycled oil they they run up
the freight to the maximum they can
which is 100 tons per car of freight
um
so
yeah there's a picture of that
transloading facility uh in Rochester
you can see the large tanks you can see
the trucks that that haul it off and uh
and the left hand side is the sand and
gravel translating facility that brings
again con wash crayons concrete sand
from up in Ossipee down to Rochester
which is about
uh 30 miles
uh so this is this is the main advantage
of rail Freight and why it's so
important you know it again it just kind
of summarizes what we talked about
but our current Freight volumes
eliminate 40 000 heavy trailer trucks or
tankers
per year from our highways 40 000 trips
per year are taken off the roads because
the railroad and and its current volumes
over the past 37 years these nhn trains
have moved over 26 million tons of
freight and that's taken 1.6 million
heavy truck trips off the highways and
bridges
um next page maintaining nhn's track
infrastructure has been a public private
partnership since 1980s
we partnered with businesses
municipalities state and federal
governments to maintain and rehabilitate
the tracks it's it's a hugely expensive
thing with hyperinflation it's been even
more so
um and it's a constant process 95 of the
rail and ties have been replaced since
1986.
um railroad ties used to have like 100
Year lifespan they don't make them like
that anymore and they used to be soaked
in creosote and you can probably
remember them as a but not anymore they
they have a they have a life that's like
25 to 40 years so the ones that were put
in back at the beginning when when the
New Hampshire North Coast started have
to be have to be replaced
New Hampshire North Coast has 49 gray
Crossings in 41 public and private roads
of which 35
are signalized at 71 we're actually
working on another one right now
um we've continuously upgraded our
Crossings and by the way the crossing
program for every Road in this country
is 603 short lines and the main lines
that's all done through federal dollars
it's a federal Crossing program the
United States government spends a lot of
money
through the states it's a mystery
through the states to the railroads to
uh to upgrade the crossings because that
is where safety I mean that's where the
the train and the public meet are at
Crossings so they have to make sure
those are safe and the government has
spent money on that and all the all the
railroads participate in that this is
just a little summary on the next page
showing the capital budget match
Appropriations for the last uh three for
New Hampshire North Coast that we were
involved with uh 1.8 million in 2017 1.8
in 2019 500 000 in 2021 uh and again
that's match money so it's 1.8 million
half 900 000 from the state 900 000 from
the from the
from the state from the railroad and the
2021 is 500 000 and even though we've
asked for more in the in the
placeholding um legislation we'll be
looking for that same amount in the next
budget 500 000 250 from the state and
250 from the railroad here's some many
of the projects at Canal Street
signalization Acton Ridge Market Street
we had a tiger Grant next page meet a
tiger Grant it's a Federal grant we were
given two million dollars
back in 2013 and the money breakdown
that was 1.4 came from the feds 450 000
came from the railroad 150 from the
state of New Hampshire
so with that they did 9 000 ties and a
linear mile of relay and two Crossings
uh
it's a lot of money but it goes fast and
just to look at it those 9 000 ties
represent I think less than
less than five percent of the of the
tire Ties on the on the rail line uh we
also had a washout you can see the
washout how it just uh
it it uh it washed out in like 2009 and
two and then we finally got the money to
fix it it was very expensive I was part
of this too and it's very important
because even though it was north of of
Osby aggregate's operations in its
mainly it ended the connectivity between
the rail and going to Conway the state
of New Hampshire
uh and Shelley Winters is here from the
from the Bureau of rail and Transit
State of New Hampshire owns
pharmaceutical Aggregates North to
Conway and that rail Corridor is being
maintained as a corridor and it with
that washout there's no Corridor a
quarter is like a chain is weakest link
uh you know would destroy the whole
thing so that was repaired and you can
see some uh before and after pictures on
the next page
uh finally just to give a
some perspective of what we do is talks
about how many ties we have 247 84
linear miles of rail uh okay here is it
hit the 13 500 ties that were installed
prior to 2018 that represented 5.5 of
the total ties
um and unexpected things can happen
which we had a washout in uh Somersworth
how that happened was the water
department wanted to flush one of their
hydrants one time
into the river into the river that runs
through Somersworth and it instead of
running the water hose over the tracks
at night to empty it they'd put it on
the other side of the tracks and the
water came under the tracks eroded it
fortunately
they were high railing in the morning
they caught it but it washed the rails
you could wash it out completely so that
closed down the rail for five weeks and
uh we had and it was a major problem
um so this Capital request this year is
is again uh for 250 000 in state funds
we got a tiger Grant I mean sorry a
Chrissy Grant granted uh two years ago
still haven't seen any money or done any
work because the permitting is just uh
horrendous
um
what we want to address with this money
that we're asking for is again more
bridges and more
culverts the Chrissy grant that we got
the Federal grant is going to deal with
the biggest problem on the railroad as
far as the bridge goes and that's in
Rochester it's the Haven Hill Bridge
it was built 160 years ago
it's uh 11 it's 11 feet high you know
literally it was in the days of horse
and Buggies so that was not a problem
but today the trucks continually smash
into the to the underpass
um
since we got the tiger Grant in October
2020 it's happened three times and I
have one picture in here of that but we
have it well documented that you know it
just keeps it keeps happening and it
will keep happening but there was one
time a garbage truck got stuck under
there mostly lately it's been box trucks
that turn into convertibles and you can
see you know they're carrying appliances
or whatever but one time a garbage truck
got stuck and it dislodged the rail and
shut down the rail for three three days
and fortunately again they on the before
the train comes down each day somebody
goes down on their truck High railing
and they noticed that there was a
problem otherwise you'd have a
derailment and then you can have a real
problem in terms of not only property
damage but but life as well
um but the we have 32 other bridges that
are all just as old and some of the
culverts just as old and we need to keep
addressing those and this money is
critically important to help that
process along uh here's some pictures on
the last couple Pages here page 12 you
see the photos of that bridge on the
right you see what happens to the truck
once it goes through that bridge
um
then you can see you know some of the
abutments pedestals
and uh
some of these Bridges how they need to
be repointed how the uh the seats
underneath them are not good and the
last page is really good because it
shows you there's there's 90 of these
culverts on the property that are that
are Granite culverts and you can see
they're just big old granite slabs that
were put under the railroad with with
top pieces
and they've lasted a long time but
eventually the motion of the railroad
and time in water just kind of pushes
them along and eventually have to be
replaced and that involves a lot of
Permitting you have to go through the
not only nhdes but Army Corps of
Engineers and on the right you can see
when we did in 2018
permits alone were 80 000 but it shows
you uh what the final product is and of
course it's a lot safer
so that's our presentation I just wanted
to uh be able to share that with you and
you have packets you can read in more
detail I'd be happy to answer any
questions you may have today and if you
need to in the future
thank you Mr Campbell is there any
questions the committee has for
Mr Campbell
microphone please
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so this is a private
corporation that bought this railroad
what kind of expectations did they have
when they bought this were they
expecting that New Hampshire would be
subsidizing portions of their business
at that time
actually the answer to that is yes I
mean it wasn't purchased without the
knowledge at the time of getting not
only some grants but a large amount of
loans that made it possible to refurbish
the line when they when they got the
when they picked up that line it was in
very very poor condition uh
I can't speak for it in the 80s but I
was there in the 90s and the last 10
miles it turned into a five mile an hour
track
no business could make that work on its
own without help from the federal
government on The Crossings and the
state of New Hampshire helped
significantly and we had we had loans
that were paid off 20-year loans that
were paid off in the last four years uh
three of them and uh
and there was a grants as well I mean
the answer is absolutely the expectation
was not that this could work without the
partnership of the State of New
Hampshire and some governmental funding
or the railroad would just turn into a
you know a bike trail follow-up
so
when I looked this up on the Internet
Boston sand and gravel owns this
and they seems like there's quite a few
companies in that orbit of Boston sand
and gravel Manchester sand and gravel
the railroad Etc so
well what's the revenue estimate of
those companies I I couldn't even tell
you I represent the railroad itself
because I saw on here I mean I can't I
can't verify between 100 and 500 million
I'm just trying to establish the you
know the value with the people who own
this
well the company has a lot of Revenue
but I know business right now is on a on
a big downturn in the city I I each
company runs on its on its own a
railroad has to run profitably or at
least near profitably in order to exist
like any other business and and I'm
telling you that the railroads in the
United States every one of them CSX
which is which by the way see just just
you know see b m became Springfield
terminal which became uh Pan Am is now
was purchased recently by CSX and CSX
they get federal funds they get Crissy
grants they get State funds all these
railroads wouldn't exist just like
highways wouldn't exist without State
funding so I understand what you're
saying you're saying well they're a rich
company they don't need money well they
do because if the railroad doesn't carry
its own weight the road can't make money
or at least and and it believe me the
railroad is right about here
and on years when you have
washouts it loses money it's never made
significant money because if they have
any kind of profit is poured back into
the into the maintenance and the
infrastructure again we're not talking
about engines and personnel and all
those things which are carried
exclusively by the private concern we're
talking about the infrastructure that's
in the ground on the state of New
Hampshire land and the state has a
vested interest
and has at least policy wise believes
they would invested interest in
maintaining that infrastructure
another follow-up
okay in 2013 you received the tiger
grant for 1.4 million plus private
matching
and when I read that
that article on that it said that the
objective was to gain customer base
uh to get gather more users for the line
so when I look at it and I'm I don't
know if I'm wrong I'm seeing that
Boston's seeing the gravel is the main
user transporting their own product in
Eastern Propane are there any more that
have been gained since 2013 10 years ago
well there has been the waste oil
company but that's actually in
Rollinsford at the very end other end of
the line
the uh that's a very good question but
in the northern part in Ossipee by
fixing that washout they opened up
hundreds of acres of land
that's now available that was not
available before has anybody come up
there yet not yet and part of the reason
was
uh we're the short line for a company to
have a company uh and make money and
have real import first it has to be the
right type of company secondly we're
just the tail at the end of the dog they
have to figure out what the rate is
going to be say from Shipping
steel for instance from Pittsburgh to
Ossipee they've got to figure up that
we've had people look at the land we've
had people think about putting other
propane uh Farms up there
nothing's happened
but the fact is because we did that
tiger Grant it did open up hundreds of
acres of land that someday will be
able to to hopefully support business
when Boston sand bought the line there
was a little industrial part in called
Knights industrial park in Rochester
and that was that became
what you see here this transloading
facility because there was a small piece
of land there I'd say small it was
probably 40 acres it's we turned it into
a trans we bought it transloading
facility and created a great customer
not only for the railroad but for the
area because by bringing again propane
in by rail safer more economic passed on
to the people who buy propane so we hope
for more we had it we had a different
propane company look at Ossipee they
looked at it for a long time they said
no but you know the fact that we did it
for a reason and hasn't come to fruition
yet
um I still believe that someday
especially with CX CSX as a partner I
think we'll get more and more customers
on the railroad
wait till appropriate time it's fine I'm
sorry I said I'm glad to take them
um
we'll go for one more in the uh in the
so the bottom line this is this is a
private company that owns this
and we as New Hampshire New Hampshire
taxpayers have contributed quite a bit
and in fact apparently Federal
so
if if this line gets upgraded from class
three tracks to class ones a
um
this company could still sell this and
New Hampshire is not going to be in as a
um well the upgrades are important but
but the classes designation won't change
it'll just mean it would be a class
three railroad with
with a good infrastructure State of New
Hampshire again puts a 10-year lien on
starting from the date of any of their
um
contributions you know if they do a 50
50 match they still put a 10 year old so
State of New Hampshire still has their
thumb on it if something ever went bad
if if they went bankrupt state New
Hampshire gets the real
so and as far as being a private concern
you're absolutely right but so are the
other 603 602 Shoreline railroads as are
all of the class one railroads which are
the big ones CSX Pan Am I mean up
uh Norfolk Southern
community and National all of those are
with the exception of Amtrak which is
run by the federal government but all
the others are private
any other questions for Mr Campbell
excuse me thank you Mr chairman
representative Campbell thank you very
much for your testimony just a quick
question because I was jotting down
notes how many miles per one gallon of
diesel
this is from the Short Line correct
Association yeah it's 470 miles for one
ton of freight
um on one diesel one gallon of diesel
fuel will move one ton of freight 470
miles
okay
follow Mr chairman
follow-up thank you
um as it relates to the culverts and the
bridges
which of the two is in utmost dire need
of repair
well we we get both Bridge inspections
and Culvert inspections so there's a
list there's a priority list of where to
spend the money which can shift from a
year I mean year to year you you look at
the after the spring thaw there could be
a sinkhole in one of the culverts so we
have our own internal list that again is
kind of fluid in the sense that it
changes as as the priorities change and
obviously if you get a actual washout or
some kind of um you know Bridge settling
uh that would jump up on the list but
the reason we don't get too far behind
on it is because we have these annual
inspections uh
for for the engineering Integrity as
well as all you know daily inspections
as far as the track Integrity goes
final follow-up Mr chairman
final follow-up thank you and along that
same line representative candle Campbell
does the acoe consult with you on those
inspections and works with you on
specific design that will improve the
Integrity of the Culvert of the bridge
we wish they did okay no but they they
don't they only come they only come when
when it's part of a permitting process
Army Corps of Engineers okay yeah
they'll they'll get involved if there's
a
if there's a permit or emergency type
you know we had an emergency permit a
few years ago we had we had a near
washout we had a club that was failing
over Christmas and you know how it is to
try to get things done over Christmas
with the US government but we actually
had the head of a New England ACO Army
Corps call up and he was an interim he
said I couldn't sleep last night
thinking about what if there's a
derailment on my watch under this on
this bridge so he expedited the permit
and got it done and you know and we we
paid for that and at the time we didn't
have any state funds but had we that's
where we'd spent some of those State
funds thank you for answering my
questions thank you Mr chairman thank
you
thank you Mr Campbell
thank you thank you all
next up we have
Mr Paul warsawitz
excellent
pronunciation
but I could have used them in the prior
uh well then my name on the prior Bill
my name would be basavich
you pronounced the W's as v's and I've
just learned that recently but Paul was
switched from galago Callahan and got
Trail I'm here today representing the St
Lawrence Atlantic Railroad
been involved in
refurbishing of the Rails from the 90s
and
we started in back in 1990 the state
passed a statute
on rebuilding modernization and
maintenance of real properties
at that time the state was
the condemnation of rail was the only
way you could get and once it was down
and out and state bought it then you
were eligible federal funds
and the leadership in the house senate
and the governor said why can't we save
the lines that are already existing
and not wait till they be deteriorated
down to class zero and then we buy them
then we got a refurbish from the
beginning
and by the way we're losing tax money
the railroads pay
we had a Statewide property tax back
over 100 years ago but money goes to
every Community where the real goes
for a quarter of the revenue that we
bring in and Gene as former speaker
Chandler and then Public Works chair
said he wanted to make sure where the
state-owned lines go they get some of
that money so it's you know besides all
make it three hundred eighty thousand
um so the concept here was save the real
lines
so we can attract companies now don't
put them into
deterioration that they have banned they
are abandoned
so there's a statute 228
66 rebuilding modernization and
maintenance of real lines it requires if
the railroads apply for this money
they have to with this we've heard about
the liens but they're supposed to keep
it up to the to the the line if we bring
it up to a class they call class two
you got to keep it that way and the
state really does a tough job on when if
a grant comes through like this bill
would provide you know if we got 500 000
for the Saint Lawrence Atlantic and
match it with 500 000. we go through a
rigorous rigorous process and eventually
goes to the governor Council but the
Department of Transportation does an
excellent job and
allocating the money and tracking it I
can tell you we had some track where we
were cutting the the rail and we were
off by
five feet they wanted to know what
happened to that five feet we found it
but they know where every piece comes it
was comes in and where it goes
so that's the process that the state
follows today
and would fall to to get to that with
this legislation
the mind that we represent represent I
passed out
it's they didn't have a Saint Lawrence
Atlantic Seaway
200 years ago
so the line comes down this was the
Saint Lawrence Atlantics Railroad and
the line came down from the Montreal
area end of Vermont but it was coming
into New Hampshire
remember we had the paper mills were
important to the to the North country
and we would take products and bring it
all the way to Portsmouth to Portland
and it would come down to Portsmouth
because we got to some this area where
we had sea sea water that wasn't Frozen
so that's what we did
so that's why I wanted to see the map
the map that you have before you the
line
is we're running on some track that was
they brought the prisoners German
prisoners to leave stock
prison and walk camp
so we have been gradually replacing them
and then what's important in New
Hampshire is the land under our railroad
real line really tracks is owned by the
state of New Hampshire
and I found this out from representative
Larry gay from Gorham they may remember
him but he called me over and said Sonny
you understand you don't own the land
we don't
I took him for his word I went and told
some Manchester lawyers and ah you don't
know what they're talking about Cape get
out of here
Larry brought me up to the archives we
come back down
uh you don't
we only own we can operate a rail on the
land owned by the state of New Hampshire
and there is a deed of that you know the
New Hampshire has
so when we took over the line
we've been gradually fixing it up and
the second page I just wanted to show
you that we this product coming into New
Hampshire that goes over that rail line
but the real cars are only filled to 80
capacity because of the track
so what we've been doing is upgrading it
so we can get it full of load
and we've been doing it working hard and
getting there now this funding that
we've been doing over you'll see the
history it really goes back to 2010
and a few years before then we've been
gradually working at it
we took you know give me two miles and
we for funding to repair two miles we
did it
it says keep moving forward
so we're down to the last 10 miles but
we because of this approach that New
Hampshire was taking with the real
Department of Transportation rail Bureau
that we have applied for a Chrissy Grant
and the people in Washington said you
know we've never seen things like this
we've got three states have applied all
working together Maine
New Hampshire and Vermont
so we made an application
we hope we don't need this money
but if we do we will continue on we
think we have a shot at it and the folks
they were very impressed that we had
three states working together and three
people were investing money
so and the state has been doing it and
again they were impressed with the
statute that we have on the books that
says would it keep maintenance of the
rail line and the state has been
actively involved
um so page three is really the Tri-State
Regional upgrade project I've got other
pitches but these trains come in leave
us leave this the rail on the side
come along take out the old reel put the
new rail on and you know it's very
impressive mechanism they go about three
miles and I got some other photos that
are worthwhile looking at to see what
the real uh how it works it's hard to
believe but it's really uh it's just a
assembly line on on the track
and then we again we have to maintain
the line You'll see on page four you'll
see some of the steel that's coming in
um and the breakdown of the work by
state but we hope to get a Chrissy Grant
and it's recognizing that
our infrastructure our real
infrastructure is needed and that this
that the government has the role to play
again we pay taxes
as I said we had a Statewide property
tax before the education folks ever
thought of it and the reason we had a
Statewide property taxes
I mean we were trying to build a
railroad in here in 1990 but then 1900s
sometimes they didn't like it coming up
across across the Massachusetts border
and it they attacked you real high
um and so they leveled it off and so it
allows the state to continue and expl
with a rail system
I let the last page is you know a brief
a history of what we've spent and how
we've done it and we're proud of it
real proud of it we've added a lot to
the economy of State of New Hampshire
and this system you know they made sure
they're tough on us we're investing a
dollar they make sure they get two
dollars back
and they do
so in a way well what we have done has
helped save the real lines in the state
of New Hampshire
and we're trying to continue that and
bring up you know try and attract more
businesses that are interested in
locating here but they want to know
transportation and rail is an important
part of it
so with that I'll be glad to answer any
questions
but that's that's again the we hope that
we get that Chrissy Grant but it's only
because of the legislature passing a
statute back in the 90s
gradually putting money into the rail
and they see it and the standards that
we've had to keep our real up to
so with that I'll be glad to answer any
questions thank you Mr Orson for that
explanation I wasn't aware of that past
legislation any questions
from the committee
saying none you got off
I'm sorry representative Boyd
thank you Mr chairman I appreciate it uh
Mr warsawitz thank you very much for
your testimony
um regarding the railroad line operating
on the land that's owned by the state of
New Hampshire is that an easement
agreement is it a lease agreement it was
there a fee agreement it's for for usage
do you have any historical background
the background was that the state wanted
to keep the land
then they allowed the railroad to invest
money to put the track down
but the land remained with the state of
New Hampshire
and for them for some reason they left
the state probably inherited the rail
but they still inherited the land they
always wanted to own the land
as representative gay told me we would
not going to let a
another country
on our land in New Hampshire it's New
Hampshire land
follow-up Mr chairman
follow-up please
um part of the line goes up into the
province of Quebec what's the
relationship with Saint Lawrence in the
province of Quebec regarding your
ability to run you have an excellent
perfect relationship
okay and lastly oh I'm sorry follow up
Mr chairman last one one final question
we're running very late on for the next
committee thank you Mr chairman uh
Presby Plastics how's that relationship
been working on in terms of the ability
to move product
so what I'm told we work well with them
okay try to promote we try to promote
out there marketing
all the time okay okay thank you Mr
chairman
thank you thank you Mr worswitz
um
representative Cloutier I know that you
have not turned in a pink card but did
you want to comment at all as being a
in favor and that's fine thank you thank
you very much then seeing uh no further
questions at this point in time we're
going to close the public hearing on HB
199.
okay
foreign
I would like to uh exec
um House Bill 199 I would like to tell
the sponsors and co-sponsors here for
our three o'clock hearing that I
apologize for this delay and we will be
with you shortly
so I'd like to
um open executive session on House Bill
199.
yes all right thank you Mr chairman I
moved to retain
motion motion has been made to retain is
there a second second Mr chairman
representative Boyd seconds
the motion
motion motion was made by representative
Jack
discussion before we move into a voting
mode
seeing none uh with the I'm sorry I
didn't see your thing yeah so represent
Kowski please
I'm going to say I'm I'm voting against
this
I believe to me this is corporate
welfare I'm not in favor of giving any
dollars to a private company
I own a private company in
transportation and I'm not I wouldn't
even expect to get money from the
citizens of New Hampshire so I can't
good conscience vote for this
thank you representative anyone else
wished to in the committee
comment I um for myself as the chairman
having sat here at least four other
times that this proposal has been
brought forward
I I believe that this is money well
spent for our state
seeing no other comment
um when the clerk has time we will call
the role to retain the motion is to
retain if you're in favor of that motion
signify by saying I yes if you're
against that proposal it would be nay or
no
thank you Mr chair
and a motion to retain representative
Cloutier yes
the clerk votes yes
representative dolfi is not here
representative Newton yeah
representative Kaczynski
representative Bowden
representative Boyd Boyd votes eye
representative Melvin
yes
representative bogert
representative Connor
representative Jack yes
representative Abbott yes
representative Edgar
aye representative Faulkner
representative Newman yes
representative Eaton
representative Peterson yes
representative vallone
representative Juris is not here
chairman McConkey
the chairman votes chairman votes eye
Mr chair the motion to retain passes 16
to 1 motion to retain passes 16-1 I will
close the executive session
and once again I apologize for the late
timing of this uh do the uh do you
members need five minutes
and we'll power through
power okay
thank you
consent calendar
um okay never mind yeah
it should be should be outside all right
foreign
have two cards
and
okay we will uh we will proceed uh the
chair will recognize representative
Thomas Walsh
good afternoon Mr chair members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Tom Walsh I'm a representative from
Merrimack District 24 which is the towns
of Hooksett and Dunbarton
I'm here to introduce House Bill 296
which is an act relative to local
Authority for granting driveway permits
uh I guess the easiest way for me to
describe this bill and what it seeks to
do is just tell you the the reason that
it happened
I also serve on the planning board and
Hooksett I have so have done so for 13
years
um
a few years ago we
adopted or approved a major subdivision
and a couple of years later somebody
bought it
and followed our subdivision to the
letter this is dealing with driveways
our current ordinance specifies 14-foot
driveways for driveways of that length
um so he went and got a building loan
construction loan and everything is
budgeted including the driveway follow
the plans to the T
and when it came and built and
constructed the 14-foot driveway this
one needed a des permit with two
culverts
um and then my phone rings when it came
time for Co
the certificate of occupancy the hooks
of fire department denied them their
certificate of occupancy saying that
they wanted a 20-foot driveway
so again that's when I got involved so
doing some investigation and talking
with them I said where are you getting
the information or the request for a
20-foot driveway
and what I was told by the the then
safety now who was now chief that it's
his interpretation of the nfpa-1 section
18 that he's got the authority to
determine that driveways of that length
are actually fire safety access roads or
fire access roads
so if you read section 18 a fire Access
Road actually talks about Gates knocks
boxes no parking signs and they're 20
feet wide so the his interpretation and
it stands to this day is that because
he's the authority having jurisdiction
in hooks it he can bring the fire code
fire access roads rules or some of them
and impose his own width on driveways
planning board followed our ordinance we
approved the drawing with 14 Footers the
owner built it to 14 feet and then his
Co was held hostage until obviously we
got into it in a little bit of pressure
was applied Etc I have tried to make
every effort to solve this in town I am
not one of those Representatives that
comes running here the first time
there's an issue but it has been very
difficult to get anywhere with it
um so that's what happened to start it
since then my phone has lit up a couple
of more times for the same issue
um I guess he's decided he can live with
16 feet rather than 20 but it's this for
the same reasons he's still looking at a
fire Access Road rule in the code and
our ordinance were never changed so this
is just merely a
a an effort and this will go into the
chapter just below single family and two
family fire sprinklers as an exception
to NFPA to say that that the codes don't
supersede what the local ordinance says
in terms of driveways and widths because
that's the only thing we're looking at
right now is widths
um there is nothing to stop the fire
department from getting involved in the
process of ordinance changes they're
actually their opinions uh weigh in
pretty heavy and I'm sure they'd be
successful and there is another
opportunity for fire departments uh if
this was adopted to chime in it's called
a technical Review Committee which all
major subdivisions go through and it's
another opportunity to make exceptions
um I just I when I have constituents
basically crying on the phone to me
because they're out of money they can't
get the CO for their new house and
they're running out of their lease on
their apartment something's got to be
done I couldn't do it in town so I'm
here now I have reached out to the dot
to make sure because I'm hearing this
this language that I get from OLS after
describing the situation might be a
little broad but it's not my intent to
affect any dot curb cut widths or or
issues on state roads because there are
residential driveways obviously on state
roads too nor am I trying to get into
any commercial Endeavors so
I've spoken with them about it I've also
spoken with with Marshall Toomey
and again I'm just really looking at
single and two family residences so I
hope to continue the discussions this
week and I may have if you find issue
with this also an amendment to try to
narrow it down and and you know maybe
address some of those concerns but that
is in a nutshell that's what happened
that's why I'm here and that's what I'm
trying to solve thank you Mr chairman
thank you
questions of the representative
by committee yes represent Barger
thank you Mr chairman
um
is it to understand that when the
planning board reviews a product or
development or whatnot it also goes to a
technical Review Committee which the
fire department is a standing portion of
that committee and they provide reports
to the planning board saying they agree
with the documents that have been
presented
uh as far as design documents and stuff
that have been presented and they agree
with that and therefore as I continue
just almost finished that's right that
in this instance a 14-foot driveway
would have been delineated on all the
drawings that the technical review board
would have had an opportunity to review
thank you for the question
representative as I said this this
subdivision did go through a technical
Review Committee at the time and the
fire department does have a seat on that
board
uh or in those meetings nothing was
mentioned at the TRC meeting everything
was fine no recommendations were made to
make any changes the driveways were in
there at 14 feet which follows our
ordinance the planning would
subsequently approved it and that's when
this gentleman with his family bought it
built it to the plans
at the time of certificate of occupancy
is when the fire department said they're
not accepting the 14-footer they want
20.
that would have been 10 literally tens
of thousands of dollars with Des permits
extended culverts not to mention the
driveway itself that's basically why I'm
thank you Mr chairman
representative Walsh was was the
ordinance
that the planning board utilized for 14
feet with ever vetted with the fire
chief
it's been thank you for the question
representative I don't know but it's
been on the books for as long as I've
been on the planning board I don't
believe there's ever been an issue if
again TRC is the opportunity for
exceptional cases for the fire
department to chime in if there's a
problem with a specific project
but they've been 14 feet for these
lengths since I've been involved I can't
tell you when it was adopted never been
an issue before okay thank you very
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
hearing my question
um has this been an ongoing problem or
is this something fairly recent say
um the life safety codes of 2015 or
adopted a few years ago is that what
kind of got things going here with thank
you for the question no that's 15 8 and
now we're in 18 which was just adopted
15 for sure 18 I believe is still the
case there is nothing in the codes that
refer to residential driveways as far as
requirements
this whole thing with the with what
they're attempting to do is using an
interpretation of what is in the code
that deals with fire access roads which
not my interpretation does that include
driveway whatsoever and it's pretty
clear driveways don't have dropping
Gates locked lock boxes and no parking
signs generally speaking so
um it's it describe what issue has been
new but other issues I guess without
going too far into it are not
representative Newman
thank you for taking this question I
just want to be clear we're talking the
width
so how wide is a fire truck
and
maybe it's better framed can a fire
truck maneuver on a 14-foot with spam
well I you would know better to meet
with the thank you for the question I
believe a fire truck is not more than
eight feet wide because they do navigate
on our city streets and and Roads and I
don't remember the exact
standard of of a lane but it's less than
14 feet so to answer your question yes
thank you for taking my question is the
planning board in your town either
elected or appointed by the elected
officials
in hooks that we are appointed thank you
thank you
thank you representative Newton
I I have a question
um
so the it sounds like the problem
started with uh or the issue
and the permitting the final permitting
happened on this driveway that you're
speaking of being 14 feet wide does that
service one one residence
yes
thank you for that
any further questions seeing no further
questions thank you for your testimony
thank you very much
um I don't know what preference you
gentlemen wish to go but I I would
recognize
foreign
I think so
good afternoon my name is Sean Toomey
I'm the State Fire Marshal
um thank you for allowing me a few
minutes to speak today I just want to
note that I did have a few a couple
conversations with representative Walsh
just trying to figure out a way to
decide to solve this problem
um it sort of pains me to hear these
issues that come up and I don't think
that uh
just a widespread statute change to
address some local issues is necessarily
the right thing to do but I also uh
need the I really want to work and
commit to helping Hooksett figure out
how to fix this because this shouldn't
be the case that someone's building a
residence or even a commercial building
and just about time for specific
democracy find out that they can't get
there because of some
misapplication of the code or some
misunderstanding I think that creates a
lot of burden on the our people that are
trying to build things in New Hampshire
just to back up I as as written I do
oppose the bill I share a letter with
you I think representative Walsh
provided a really good
um
background of why and how we're here
today and as I said we've talked a
couple times to try to figure out how to
address the specific issue whether
that's an amendment to this code or
excuse me amendment to this bill or uh
preferably I think for me would be to
follow the state fire code process and
bring an amendment to the board of Fire
Control and then which would be ratified
by the legislative body within a year so
we have the saf FML 300 rules which have
a handful of amendments that are made
that are vetted by the members of the
board of Fire Control with public input
to address any specific concerns that
come from the national quotes for New
Hampshire uh I think the
um
the issue around 20 foot width for a
driveway has been in the codes for more
than 20 years as best I can figure I
went back to the 2000 edition this
morning just to double check and it had
been there without really any change the
challenge I think over the years has
been there's a little flexibility at the
local level to adjust that 20-foot
requirement and I think that became
really becomes a problem at the end of
the day that you can't for a single
family home or two family home for or
for a small commercial building for that
matter to bring it down to something
less than 20 feet when we introduced the
2018 codes and in this this body's heard
the and helped to bring those forward
last year the 2018 codes allows gives
the ability at the local level to
clearly reduce the width to something
less than 20 feet and I think that it
provided some great flexibility at the
local level it frankly I've been at the
State Fire Marshal's Office for about
five year just just about five years now
the last year and a half is the Marshall
and I will say that fire department
access and water supply are probably one
of the bigger questions that we get for
technical questions from the locals and
and since the 18 codes have come into
play I think we've seen a decrease in
those questions because the locals have
the ability to decrease that that width
having done some research on the
Hooksett issue specifically I I walk
away with a scratch in my head a little
bit but the driveway application says 12
feet the
um the planning raises we heard are 14
feet and then there's a one pager that
the fire department has it says 16 feet
but then talk somewhere somewhere else
it says you can do 14 feet again so
anytime you have that couple
documentations from the officials that
have that much confusion I don't know
what to do with I mean that's that's
terrible for someone trying to do some
development so I think those the local
stuff needs to get cleaned up
um
and I I guess I making a drastic change
to the fire coat or at the in the
statute here is is probably in my
opinion not the the most appropriate
place but we definitely need to fix it I
think the fire department access issues
need to be kept with the fire
departments because they really know
about tactical and operational
considerations
um when we're needing to access
someone's property for uh whether it's
life safety or property preservation it
could be as simple as getting an
ambulance into somebody's house I've
been on numerous scenes I was out of
fire just recently in the last couple
weeks that the fire truck couldn't make
it into someone's driveway and it slowed
down the operations in the the house the
second floor was in the roof where it
was burned off that was in the Town of
Warner
um
can I save 100 that that the lake was a
huge break you know break the breaking
point I I guess I can't but I know I've
watched Force hand because I live in the
community and watch the delay it caused
for the the fire department getting to
the building getting water on the fire
so I mean I think that
um I was kind of joking with the
representative Walsh we we got to figure
out a happy medium of we can't go back
to car paths or you know something very
small but we also I think you need to
provide some firm uh guidance that maybe
a 12-foot driveway for instance is a
good minimum requirement for a uh for a
single family home or one family home
where I personally live on a uh I drive
was a quarter mile long it's about 10 to
12 feet wide on the gravel
um
you know I know a fire department the
truck can get down there I've had it
down there for my kids
um you know years ago but uh
you know so something much smaller we
can't get the trucks in so I think that
uh you know the one the one that'll
close with this the and I don't have the
exact language in front of me but nfpa1
and the question about whether it
applies to one in two families homes
I've had conversations with the AG's
office and there's certain Provisions
that clearly
um that do apply
in this specific section in chapter 18
that we're talking about uh one of the
exceptions to a 20-foot driveway is a
home that sprinkled
um that's I believe it's the exception
number one but I don't quote me I could
get it to if you if you really need to
but
um as we know in in our state we've
Exempted the sprinklers for one two
family home so
um the the NFPA one definitely applies
in specific cases to
um to the residential structures I'll go
back and just share one one other little
tidbit one in the 15 codes and now it's
in the 18 codes but we had a lot of
conversations several years ago about
floor protection for the light weight
construction homes now and how they burn
much faster and we amended the state
fire code the 401 and two family homes
to provide some protection of the floor
structure so that it slows down the the
compromise to the system for instance if
there was a basement fire so there there
are definitely Provisions in the state
fire code for one and two family homes
it's just our ability to regulate and
inspect and and deal with single-family
homes is is very much different than
commercial structure so I've been
answering questions
um and I've provided sort of a summary
letter for you to review thank you sir
thank you
represent Boyd please
thank you Mr chairman and Marshall
Toomey thank you very much for your
testimony I took the opportunity to pull
a section out of the state fire code for
Dimensions which talks about
182351 and then 18 23511 which talks
about access roads unobstructed with no
less than 20 20 feet the section with
with three ones at the end of it gives
flexibility to the ahj The Authority
having jurisdiction to lessen that width
at 20 feet and you testified that your
road is 12 feet I guess my question to
you is in in your professional opinion
do you think amending
18235-111 in the fire code to say no
less than 12 feet may add Clarity to the
ahj in in identifying what that
flexibility could be in terms of
determining the width of a residential
driveway I think that would be a pro
appropriate and I think that would be a
great starting point to bring an
amendment forward state of the board of
Fire Control with a 12-foot here at
public hearing from the fire officials
and some of the other contractors and
and try to provide some baseline some
guidance I appreciate your answer thank
you thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative Boyd further question yes
represent Faulkner thank you Mr chairman
uh could you clarify for me what how do
you measure the unobstructed width is
that the width of the pavement or is it
the width to posts or anything else on
the side because it seems if you have 14
feet of pavement
you have a three foot shoulder or
clearance on the side it doesn't have to
be paved you don't have the impact on
the wetlands Etc but you still have
clearance for the sides of the of the
truck
is there a way to measure a standard for
how we measure what the unobstructed
with this thank you no I would say
there's probably not the clearing the
clarity that should be in some of that
requirement
um the what I typically fall back when I
provide guidance is it talks about being
able to Bear the weight of the apparatus
so if you had a 12 foot paved driveway
and you were looking for a 14 or you
know if you would add some gravel
shoulders and that might be appropriate
as we know many homes in New Hampshire
are just gravel driveways so
um mud season you just you want to make
sure you have a a suitable surface that
can hold the apparatus weight and uh I
think the unobstructed really tends to
be it wants to be a box of
and if you took the extreme 20 foot wide
by 13-6 so you can get the apparatus
down the driveway so
um but uh it's my opinion that you can
go a little smaller if you if you have
suitable shoulders
but it's not as clear as it probably
could be
thank you representative
yes
I'm sorry representative please
thank you Mr chairman uh is there any uh
delineation between
uh like you said your driveway it was 90
feet long and then if you had a brand
new development that had houses
multiple houses with the driveway of 15
feet long
does that change the requirement of it
as I say it I've never seen in a Housing
Development where an ambulance or a fire
truck or anything where people had 15 20
foot driveways drove on the driveway
because it would probably crack the
driveway and sink into it because
they're not built to that standard I
believe but I'm just curious is there a
difference
between that 90 foot long driveway or in
a 15 foot long driveway
as far as length so thank you so the
question about length there there is
some guidance in there that typically
within
um I believe it's 50 feet to double
check but I believe it's 50 feet from
the from the fire department access
point to the door to get to is really
what the some of the guidance is
typically so that
um and then there's some discussion in
the code that if it's over a certain
distance I believe it's 150 feet that
you need some sort of turnaround
typically to get
um get yourself turned around back out
and also you're not backing out of the
driveway so that there definitely is
some guidance I I don't have the numbers
memorized but
um I can absolutely get that to you for
sure if you would like it but there is
different Milestones based on the the
distance to help get into the access
one follow-up certainly
now would that make the difference
between something being called an access
road and a driveway is that that
difference when you said something needs
to be at the end for the turnaround and
stuff
so that the uh the fire department
Access Road discussion talks about like
fire Lanes
um roads uh had a couple words and then
it says like any combination of thereof
so it's it's the fire department Access
Road definition is pretty broad
the the intent is for us to be able to
get to you to provide uh whatever
Services we're there for whatever
Emergency Services were there for
um you know we
we got to be able to get there to help
you that's really what it is yeah
so that definition is a little bit Broad
thank you representative Melvin
thank you
and thank you for taking my question how
would this affect uh a 2 000 foot
so I think the the private road would
follow the same requirements under the
the uh the fire department access
Provisions
um
it would start at 20 feet and then in a
community they could talk about being a
little bit less
um you know I think the the initial
discussion around the 20-foot width is
so that two fire apparatus can pass each
other if they need to so you're not you
don't get into a situation where you've
locked up the driveway and you can't
you're stuck you can't get anything in
and out
um you know go to a go to a fire scene
and you you put an ambulance and an
engine in the in the in the driveway for
a very long driveway first you've got a
patient a victim from a fire and now you
potentially you're trapped in the
driveway it impedes our ability to help
somebody you know I I don't want to be
like
horrible extremists on their discussions
but that that's really in the code it
talks about the ability for two vehicles
to pass each other it's really it's
that's what the commentary talks about
thank you for taking my question thank
you
thank you any further questions by the
committee
we have one more card here from uh Dave
Emmanuel Emmanuel is that correct sir
yes sir thank you
thank you Mr chairman uh my name is Dave
Emmanuel I am the chief of the Durham
fire department and I'm here today
representing the New Hampshire Fire
Chiefs Association and I just wanted to
state that we're opposed to the
legislation is written but we're
interested in working with a sponsor
representative Welsh on amendments or
we're concerned about the nature and our
my experience in Durham we've had a
number of similar
concerns with driveway and fire
department access and ours have
predominantly been on Legacy
subdivisions that have been approved
years ago but we still have the same
concerns for how we will get in and uh
to support the people
questions from the committee
yes represent Boyd thank you Mr chairman
and chief thank you for your testimony
basically the same question for that I
posed to Marshall Toomey
um ah Jade's up to 20. he's saying 12
feet with work in your professional
opinion do you think a minimum of 12
feet with with work based on you know
your experience
I I like thank you for your question
it's never that easy
um I understand that that's why I said
in your professional opinion
the things that we concerned or are
concerned often about the height width
length and load bearing capacity of the
driveway and we work locally since the
code changed or I got to know the State
Fire Marshal pretty well because we'd
had a number of these come forward over
the past few years when we are allowed
to make accommodations locally we can
work with the local boards to provide
other accommodations like pull-offs so
two apparatus can pass each other at
certain points along the way so we don't
plug the driveway and we can pass or to
put a turnaround at the end so I do
support we think we can support
accommodations and 12 feet we I would
agree in my opinion that's enough for a
fire truck as long as you have other
accommodations in place for long
driveways thank you for your answer
appreciate it thank you Mr chairman
thank you and anyone else with further
question
I have a question if I could and I'm not
certain whether it should go to the fire
marshal or whether it should go to you
so indulge me
the town planning board regulations say
14 foot wide driveway
this conversation is getting us back to
12 feet I've developed enough property
knowing that 14 is probably a nice width
it's wider than a single Lane of most of
your roads that go out into your
communities
so the the planning board has this
regulation and I don't know which one of
you gentlemen became involved later to
to do the occupancy permit was that you
sir or you sir and the decision came
down to
that it had to now go to 20 feet I'm
confused on that issue was it either of
you gentlemen yes sir
so
I'll give you the speaker button come on
in Sean yep thank you thank you for
coming forward welcome so the uh
the descript the scenario that
representative Walsh described was
specific to the town of Hooksett and the
Hooksett fire chief okay um so it wasn't
either of us
um the guidance that I know I provided
at the state level as the State Fire
Marshal was to be flexible and and not
for a single family home not be not be
20 feet if 14 feet if your community
likes 14 feet pick 14 feet if you pick
16 feet Pick 6 16 feet my guidance is
pick something make it clear on what
through your rule regulation however so
people know what to expect when they
come into your community so it's not a
guessing game okay thank you gentlemen
for answering that question for me I I
have nothing else at this time are there
any further questions
seeing none from the committee thank you
both and thank you all three for your
testimony
foreign
thank you for that
um okay so that that calls a conclusion
to this hearing of uh House Bill
296 we will not deliberate on this today
um in hopes that the sponsor and might
be able to come back with an amendment
that might be favorable to all those
here
um and do that as soon as you can so
with that I will call a close to uh